[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar using cutting edge stem cell
technology to model human cardiac
diseases i am sydney mcneil of lab roots
and i'll be your moderator for today's
event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by miltoni biotech
to learn more visit miltoniubiotech.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
we only have ariane with us for 30
minutes today
any questions that we are unable to
answer will be answered by our speaker
via the email address you provided at
the time of registration
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits
i would like to now welcome our speaker
post-doctoral fellow dr ariane caudle
from the laboratory of dr joseph wu
in the cardiovascular institute at
stanford university ariane you may now
begin your presentation
well thank you very much for that very
kind introduction
i'm truly honored and excited to be here
so thank you very much for the
invitation
today my talk is entitled
using cutting edge stem cell technology
to model human cardiac diseases so let's
get started
for today's presentation i'm very
excited to share our group's
contributions to the exciting field of
cardiac diseases and induced pluripotent
stem cell or ipsc technology
i'll first introduce some central themes
with some relevant background and then
i'll spend a lot of time in the
following three main sections
first how we generate and maintain ipsc
lines
next how we can differentiate these
lines into cardiac cell types and then
finally how we can use these models as
viable tools to study disease
with specific emphasis on some exciting
therapeutic targets that our lab has
elucidated in the past few years
finally i'll summarize what we have
learned today and discuss some possible
directions for the future of this
technology
so cardiovascular disease
which is broadly defined as
pathologies of the heart blood vessels
and the vascular system of the brain
accounts for nearly one-third of total
deaths worldwide
there are various etiologies of
cardiovascular disease
that exist and here i've highlighted
just a few of them
but for today's talk we'll focus on just
one specific type of cardiovascular
disease
which is the dilated cardiomyopathies
for the rest of the talk this will be
abbreviated as dcm
so with a prevalence of at least one in
every 2 500 people dcm is the most
common cause of heart failure after
coronary artery disease
as well as the leading indication for
heart transplant
the cost of managing dcm in the u.s
alone has been estimated to be between 4
and 10 billion annually
gcm is characterized by ventricular
chamber dilation or enlargement
and thinning of the heart wall as
depicted by this schematic
highlighting just the left ventricles
dcm can be clearly observed using
ultrasound
as i'm showing here from patients
and furthermore histological analysis of
patient cardiac tissues reveals very
striking changes at the cellular level
between healthy and dcm patients
part of the difficulty with treating dcm
is that it has really broad molecular
manifestations
so mutations in genes encoding
sarcomeric
cytoskeletal
mitochondrial
nuclear membrane and even calcium
metabolism proteins account for nearly
50 percent of dcm cases
and although there are at least 33 genes
associated to dates
over 75 percent of the known cases have
mutations residing in just a handful of
genes some of which i've highlighted in
this table
in today's talk i'll further highlight
two key genes
lamin a
which structurally supports the cell's
nuclear envelope
and the cardiac troponin t which is part
of the contractile machinery of the
heart that helps it beat
there is a clear need for new therapies
and cutting-edge therapeutics for
cardiovascular diseases
however there are still several barriers
to research
so first the cardiomyocytes are
post-mitotic
meaning unlike many cell types they will
not divide in a dish so we can't just
continuously grow them in the lab
so patient samples are therefore very
limited
and
healthy controls which we need for
comparison are even more difficult to
obtain
so historically animal models have been
used
but they remain a low throughput and
very expensive option and it's not
compatible with with high throughput
drug screening
furthermore small animal models don't
fully recapitulate human cardiac
physiology
and there are inherent differences in
heart rate and disease progression
our lab utilizes the induced pluripotent
stem cell or ipsc platform to model
cardiac diseases from humans
this model has many key advantages
the first is that stem cells can be
differentiated into a variety of
specialized cells
some of which we can recapitulate in a
lab
including our favorites the cardiac cell
types
and therefore stem cells can provide a
limitless material for research
in our case this circumvents the
post-mitotic nature of the adult
cardiomyocyte
second they genetically match the people
that they are derived from
meaning that we can study many different
types of heart diseases across a wide
range of demographics and populations
and that sample is more relevant to
designing therapies
third the cell-based format is very
compatible with large-scale screening of
different drugs
gene therapies and intervention
strategies which we can then directly
test the effects of
with cell-based functional readouts
so how exactly do we do this
here is a general overview of our ipsc
pipeline
we start with somatic cells from
patients
usually in the form of blood or skin
fibroblasts because those are easy to
extract
and we reprogram them into ipscs
then we differentiate into our cell type
of interest
and then we use combinatorial strategies
to determine disease mechanisms
then try to interrogate and rescue them
our end goal is to find viable treatment
strategies that are translational to
clinical applications
so first let's dive in detail into what
reprogramming actually is
and how we generate validate and
characterize ipsc lines
i thought i would share our most recent
publication from the lab led by
postdoctoral fellow dr sancho
published in january in stem cell
research
here our lab generated three
heterozygous laminae mutation carrying
ipsc lines from three cardiac
laminopathy patients
laminae is a rod-shaped structural
scaffold of the nucleus
it forms these long tetrameric bundles
that functionally supports
and organize chromatin and therefore
playing an important role in dna
replication and signal transduction
mutations in laminae
called laminopathies
largely result in cardiac diseases such
as dcm
but the underlying mechanisms still
remain unclear
therefore having models for
laminopathies where we can test drugs
are incredibly valuable resources
so from three dcm patients two male and
one female blood was collected
peripheral blood mononuclear cells or
pbmcs
were isolated from the blood using
separation techniques
and then stabilized in media and
supplements
next we use vectors based on a modified
non-transmissible form of sending virus
to safely and effectively deliver and
express key genetic factors
necessary for reprogramming somatic
cells into ipscs
and then clonally select for cells that
were transduced
once we have single colonies we let the
now ips cells recover and propagate
and typically the cell culture media of
ipscs needs to be replaced every day
however we recently switched to using
stem max ips brew media which only
requires a media change every two days
which just greatly improves the
day-to-day practicality of using ipsc
models
and as you can see the cells are both
happy and healthy
one of the first things we validate is
cell morphology and genotype so here you
can see the very quintessential
stem cell morphology is present in all
three patient lines
these patients have a mutation in the
lamin a gene
which changes uh guanine to adenine to
single base permutation that essentially
changes
arginine 133 to glutamine and this amino
acid resides in the central raw domain
of the laminae protein
we are able to validate the mutation is
present in all three lines using sanger
sequencing
next we look at the whole genome array
and validate that each ipsc cell line
has a normal karyotype
and then we look by quantitative rtpcr
that the sendai virus that we use for
reprogramming
which is non-integrating is no longer
present in the cell
here we use an early passage ipsc line
as a positive control
and a late passage ipsc line as a
negative control and as you can see at
late passages all three cell lines
express very low to no sev transcript
next we use immunostaining to look for
the key pluripotency markers nanog sox2
and ox34
as you can see these cells express all
three markers which all have high
detectable transcript levels
finally we validate each cell line's
differentiation potential
so stem cells should have the capacity
to become all three germ layers right
the outer ectodermine or the outer
ectoderm
which essentially becomes uh skin cells
pigment cells and neurons the middle
mesoderm
which for us is very important right
because that yields all of the muscle
and the inner endoderm
so to confirm we stand for derm layer
specific markers
and then show
that these lines can therefore
differentiate into all three
germ layers and there have been
successfully reprogrammed
once we have functional ipsc lines we
then differentiate them into cardiac
cell types
for today's talk i'll focus mostly on
ips derived cardiomyocytes
ipscs first become committed mesoderm
before becoming cardiac progenitors and
then early cardiomyocytes
and as early cardiomyocytes they will
begin to physically beat in a dish you
can very easily see this by light
microscope
and then further maturation of the
cardiomyocytes
just with prolonged culture
or other genetic or molecular
interventions increasingly starts to
resemble the transcriptional profile of
mammalian models
logistically this takes about 30 days in
the lab to get from ipsc to
cardiomyocyte
starting from the ips brew this requires
several media changes
alongside interrogation of wind
signaling
to yield committed mesoderm
then addition of insulin when the cells
start beating
and then two days of glucose-free
lactate selection to increase purity
using this strategy we can generate
patient-matched ipsc-derived
cardiomyocytes
to exemplify this work i'll briefly
describe this paper from our lab
led by dr ning sun and published in 2012
in science translational medicine
where
patient derived ipsc lines
were used to model dilated
cardiomyopathies
here we generated cardiomyocytes from
ipscs derived from patients in a dcm
family
carrying a point mutation in the gene
encoding the sarcomeric protein cardiac
troponin t
cardiac troponin t plays a role in the
contractile machinery of the heart
and compared to control healthy
individuals
cardiomyocytes derived from dcm patients
exhibited abnormal distribution of
sarcomeric alpha actinin
i'm shown here in red by immunostaining
and as you can see in the merge there
are these tiny pancta in the dcm cells
that are not present in the control
they also have abnormal calcium ion
regulation
detected here with representative line
scan images and decreased spontaneous
calcium transients
and therefore and furthermore if you can
take these cells and make embroidered
bodies
which are three-dimensional aggregates
of cells and stress them with norin or
norepinephrine
the dcm embryo bodies have a very poor
response and greatly diminished beating
rate
followed by sarcomeric disarray and cell
disorganization as you can see from the
immunostaining
to summarize the cells demonstrated in a
dish
common phenotypes of
observed in dcm patients
so
how can we further use this model to
gain new therapeutic insight
so at the time circa
2a gene therapy
and
metametoprolol
both had positive effects in dcm trials
but the underlying mechanism for why
they worked was still unresolved
hence our lab set out to investigate if
these mechanisms of dcm repair could be
recapitulated in a dish
so alongside improvements in gene
expression in dcm
the circa
to a
over expression improved contraction
force
as measured by atomic force microscopy
in parallel they found that metoprolol
treatment for one week significantly
decreased the number of single dcm
cardiomyocytes with disorganized
sarcomeres
these results suggest that blockade
of the beta-adrenergic pathway help dcm
ipsc derive cardiomyocytes to resist
mechanical
deterioration
and improve their myofilament
organization
to further explore beta adrenergic
signaling in ipsc cardiomyocytes and its
role in dcm
authors from our lab tried using beta
agonists so this study was led by dr
howdy wu
and was published in cell stem cell in
2015.
here they found that the beta-adrenergic
agonist isoproterenol
induced mature beta-adrenergic signaling
becomes compromised in disease
in order to test the effects of
beta-adrenergic stimulation
ipsc cardiomyocytes were next treated
with isoproterenol and spontaneous
calcium transients were analyzed
isoproterenol
increases cardiac contractility so while
the control cells respond to
isoproterenol challenge
the dcm cells do not
although expression levels of several
beta adrenergic signaling components
were unaltered between the control and
dcm ipsc cardiomyocytes they actually
found that the phosphodiesterases
pde2a and 3a were upregulated in dcm
cardiomyocytes
so the phosphodiesterase is essentially
cleave cyclic amp and this is a very
important process
in a lot of different cell pathways
but notably the pharmacologic inhibition
of the pde2a
and pde3a restored cyclic amp levels and
actually immediately ameliorated the
impaired vaginertic signaling of dcm
cardiomyocytes suggesting that
the therapeutic potential of of
targeting these pdes
so these studies um especially this one
really shows
you know
what kind what pathways are important in
the normal cell and in the disease cell
but importantly also presents a solution
and that's essentially what our lab
looks for in
in um
in interesting projects and
collaborations
in summary i showed you how our group is
using patient derived cells for
reprogramming of ipscs
we discussed how cardiomyocytes can be
differentiated and then i showed you two
examples
of how these models have been employed
to gain a deeper understanding of dcm
pathogenesis
to conclude
ipsc technology offers an exceptional
opportunity for creating disease
specific cellular models
investigating underlying mechanisms and
optimizing therapy
in the future we hope to really come
full circle to continue to integrate
other cardiac cell types into these
systems so today i talked about
cardiomyocytes we can also make cardiac
endothelial cells and fibroblasts we can
put them together in really interesting
combinations and stoichiometries
to really fully recapitulate that
complex cellular
microenvironment
and by doing that we get closer to
disease
therapies that are
eventually going to be more
applicable to translational applications
so we want to come full circle and we
want to generate novel therapies and
models that can actually help real world
patients
um and and to really to do that in a
manner that is personalized to that
patient and what they need
i'd like to thank my lab and my mentor
dr josephu
the stanford biobank
and cvi is listed here
and my funding sources so thank you
everyone for your attention
um i'm very happy to take any comments
or questions
um yeah thank you
all right thank you arianne for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you would
like to ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on your screen we will answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
let's get started our first question is
our ipsc derived
cardiomyocytes exactly like adult
cardiomyocytes what are some limitations
to the model
that's a great question
so they are not exactly like adult
cardiomyocytes comparatively they are
still quite immature in
morphology metabolism and some of the
ion channels
however there has been a lot of work
from a lot of different labs
for strategies to improve the maturation
phenotypes
so a lot of people are either using
genetic strategies
changing metabolism which means like
changing the media how much glucose to
give how much fatty acids to give
people are trying mechanical force
electrical stress
lots of different options and a lot of
them are are very promising i think to
date kind of a
combined approach
is the gold standard but there are
definitely
ways to improve the model so it's a
great question
great thank you our next question is
can you put different types of ipsc
derived self together to stimulate the
cardiac environment
yes great question absolutely um i tried
to kind of allude to this allude to this
uh this is something that i find really
fascinating so you can put cells
together you can put them as a so-called
co-culture so in a monolayer just in a
dish you can put cells together and see
how they interact with each other
physically
you can also kind of put them on
different platforms so they're not
physically touching but
that's kind of a way to look at what
signals are secreted between them
this allows you to kind of detect
self-cell communications
which is a clue to how you know disease
propagates across the whole organ so
that's actually a very important facet
of our research
the other thing you can do is to grow
different cell types as
three-dimensional aggregates
they're called engineered heart tissues
ehts
you essentially take millions of cells
and you grow them in a mold
around two posts they kind of engraft
and you form a tissue
that beats as one unit it's very cool
and it's it's much more
relevant than some of the monolayer
models so yes you can and it's a very
exciting and really beautiful part
if you look in some of our publications
you can see
what these look like and i'd highly
recommend it
perfect thank you our next question is
besides genetic models what other types
of stress can ipsc-based models be used
to study
oh okay um yes so in the example shown
today i mostly show genetic models or
stress induced by drugs but actually
we're interested in lots of different
types of stress so we're looking at
kind of environmental stress
we're even looking at radiation exposure
hypoxia
changes in diet et cetera
um those are all things we can certainly
model on a cell-based platform
personally i'm also interested in in
physiological stress
such as exercise and pregnancy and
things like that um those are a little
bit more difficult to model
uh in in cell culture but i hope to soon
get there thanks for your question
thank you our last question is you
mentioned using patient-derived cells
but can ipscs be generated from healthy
people too
yes yes so this is a very interesting
question
um we typically look at patients just
because we want to find
therapies
but but i actually think that you also
need to look at healthy people too right
and so
um from the healthy people we're we're
looking
mostly across different ethnic groups
gender you know things that can really
affect the genetic background and then
and then trying to kind of tease out
how that manifests into cellular
phenotypes
it's very difficult to do that but i
think it's really an important platform
to understand the cohesive model
so that's definitely of high interest
here thank you for your question
thank you again arianne for your time
today do you have any final remarks
yeah thank you for having me i i just
want to kind of advocate for our work
if you find any part of this
presentation
exciting at all please reach out
email me with your questions
i'll get back to you as soon as i can
and also know that our lab is very open
to collaboration
and sharing any of these models
so please check out our lab websites
the wu lab at stanford cardiovascular
institute
and reach out if
if you want to work with us we're very
excited thank you
thank you again arianne for your time
today and your important research we
would also like to thank labruz and our
sponsor miltenu biotech for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye
you